THAT'S TONIGHT ANGLE.
PRESIDENT BIDEN IS GETTING TO
BED EXTRA EARLY TONIGHT I AM
TOLD THERE LAST NIGHT'S KENNEDY
CENTER HONORS HAD HIM OUT WAY
PAST HIS BEDTIME.
HOBNOBBING WITH BETH MIDLER AND
LORNE MICHAELS WAS THOROUGHLY
EXHAUSTING ANYWAY.
TOMORROW HE'S GOING TO DIAL INTO
WHAT'S BEING DUBBED A VIRTUAL
SUMMIT WITH VLADIMIR PUTIN.
AT THE TOP OF THE DISCUSSION
LIST IS UKRAINE WHERE RUSSIAN
TROOPS ARE A MASS OF THE BORDER.
SPEAK WITH THE LATEST SATELLITE
IMAGES SUGGEST MOSCOW IS ENGAGED
IN UNPRECEDENTED BUILDUP NEAR
THE UKRAINIAN FRONTIER PAID
ENOUGH TO MOUNT AN OVERWHELMING
INVASION.
>> U.S. INTELLIGENCE HAS RUSSIA
IS PREPARING TO INVADE UKRAINE
WITH NEARLY 175,000 TROOPS.
>> TENS OF THOUSANDS OF RUSSIAN
TROOPS HAVE DEPLOYED ON ITS
BORDER WITH UKRAINE, REVEALED IN
THE SATELLITE IMAGES.
>> Laura: THE SAD FACT IS
BIDEN IS SO WEAK THAT PUTIN
FEELS PERFECTLY COMPETENT TO
START ISSUING DEMANDS EVEN
BEFORE THE TALKS BEGIN.
PRESIDENT VLADIMIR PUTIN IS
EXPECTED TO ISSUE
PRESIDENT BIDEN AN ULTIMATUM
DURING THEIR VIDEO MEETING
TUESDAY.
GUARANTEE THAT NATO WILL NEVER
EXPAND INTO UKRAINE, OR RUSSIA
MIGHT SOON LAUNCH AN OFFENSIVE
AGAINST ITS NEIGHBOR.
THE UKRAINIAN DEFENSE IN A STIR
ON CNN GIVING BIDEN ADVICE.
>> I WOULD LIKE TO ASK HIM TO
VERY UNDERSTANDABLE ARTICULATE
TO MR. PUTIN THAT NO REDLINES
FROM KREMLIN SIDE COULD BE HERE.
REDLINE IS HERE IN UKRAINE.
IT NEEDS ORGANIZATIONAL
WEAPONRY.
WE NEED ELECTRONIC WARFARE.
ET CETERA.
>> Laura: THE ET CETERA IS
WHAT COSTS A LOT OF MONEY.
HE CLAIMED UKRAINE WON'T NEED
U.S. OR NATO BOOTS ON THE
GROUND, WE KNOW HOW RISKY THIS
SITUATION IS.
ESPECIALLY WITH INCOMPETENTS
LIKE GENERAL MARK MILLEY AND
DEFENSE SECRETARY LLOYD AUSTIN
IN CHARGE.
THEY COULDN'T BEAT THE TALIBAN.
WE WERE HUMILIATED IN
AFGHANISTAN BUT THEY ARE GOING
TO SCARE OFF PUTIN?
BY THE WAY, ALL THIS IS
UNFOLDING AS AMERICANS TRUST IN
THE MILITARY IS DECLINING.
ONE RECENT HOME I FOUND THAT
JUST 40% OF AMERICANS PLACED A
GREAT DEAL OF TRUST IN THE U.S.
MILITARY.
THAT'S DOWN -- FROM 70% IN
NOVEMBER 2018 AND DROPPING 11%
SINCE FEBRUARY.
FOR SOME REASON, THE BIDEN TEAM
THINKS PUTIN WILL BE INTIMIDATED
BY STATE DEPARTMENT SPOKESPERSON
NED PRICE.
>> IF RUSSIA CHOOSES TO FAIL TO
DE-ESCALATE, IF RUSSIA CHOOSES
TO MOVE FORWARD WITH ANY PLANS
IT MAY HAVE DEVELOPED TO
CONTINUE WITH MILITARY
AGGRESSION UPON UKRAINE TO
VIOLATE UKRAINE SOVEREIGNTY, ITS
INDEPENDENCE, TERRITORIAL
INTEGRITY, WE END OUR ALLIES
WOULD BE PREPARED TO ACT.
>> Laura: IS IT JUST ME OR
DOES HE SEEM TO BE LIKE A LITTLE
BOY WHO JUST RUMMAGE THROUGH HIS
DAD'S CLOSET AND IS WALKING
AROUND THE HOUSE WEARING HIS
SUIT AS A GAG?
THE MUCH MORE PASSIVE TONE LEADS
CLONES USE WHEN THEY ARE TALKING
ABOUT CHINA.
>> WE ARE CLEAR-EYED ABOUT THE
CHALLENGE CHINA PRESENTS.
CHINA IS NOT 10 FEET TALL.
>> DO YOU THINK IT'S TIME TO
SPEAK MORE BOLDLY OR CLEARLY
WHEN REFERRING TO CHINA AND ITS
COMMUNIST AMBITIONS?
>> I THINK WE ARE DOING A LOT OF
THAT.
WE'LL CONTINUE TO SPEAK VERY
CLEARLY ABOUT OUR CONCERNS.
BUT AGAIN, WE ARE IN A
COMPETITION WITH CHINA.
WE DON'T HAVE TO BE IN A
CONFLICT.
>> Laura: BUT CONFLICT IS
PRECISELY WHAT PLENTY IN THE
MILITARY INDUSTRIAL ARE ITCHING
FOR IN THE RUSSIA-UKRAINE
SITUATION.
PUBLICLY, AUSTEN KEPT THE
CONVERSATION VERY GENERAL.
>> WE ARE GOING TO REMAIN
ENGAGED WITH OUR ALLIES IN THE
REGION, OUR PARTNERS IN THE
REGION.
WE ARE GOING TO CONTINUE TO DO
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO HELP
PROVIDE UKRAINE THE CAPABILITY.
>> Laura: TRANSLATIONS:
AMERICA WILL FOOT THE BILL
AGAIN.
THE UKRAINIANS KNOW THIS AND
THEY ARE GLEEFULLY FANNING THE
FLAMES.
>> I WILL NOT BELIEVE THAT
RUSSIA WILL HAVE A VICTORY.
RUSSIAN GUYS ALSO WILL COME BACK
IN A COFFIN.
>> Laura: COFFIN.
THIS TYPE OF RHETORIC IS REALLY
FOOLISH.
IF OUR SO-CALLED EUROPEAN ALLIES
WERE SO WORRIED ABOUT RUSSIA,
WHERE ARE THEY BUYING SO MUCH
NATURAL GAS FROM THEM?
WHY DO NATO COUNTRIES INVEST A
LITTLE IN THEIR OWN MILITARY?
THE E.U.'S ECONOMY AS MULTIPLES
BIGGER THAN RUSSIA.
GERMANY'S ALONE IS MORE THAN
TWICE AS BIG.
SO WHY ISN'T GERMAN FUNNELING
TROOPS EASTWARD?
THE ANSWER IS THEY DON'T REALLY
CARE ABOUT UKRAINE.
IF RUSSIA IS SUCH A MENACE, WHY
DID BIDEN APPROVE NORD STREAM 2?
IF YOU ARE REALLY WORRIED ABOUT
RUSSIA, HE WOULD WANT TO KEEP
OUR ENERGY PRICES LOW HERE AT
HOME.
THE TRUTH IS BIDEN GAVE PUTIN A
HUGE AMOUNT OF LEVERAGE AND HE'S
ABOUT TO USE IT TO EMBARRASS
BIDEN ON THE WORLD STAGE WHICH
WE TOLD YOU WHAT HAPPENED.
DECLARING WAR ON AMERICA'S
ENERGY INDEPENDENCE WILL ONLY
MAKE US WEAKER ACROSS THE BOARD.
SO RIGHT NOW REPUBLICANS ON THE
HILL SHOULD BE LAYING DOWN A
MARKER ON THIS RUSSIA-UKRAINE
ISSUE.
THE G.O.P. POSITION SHOULD BE
THAT WE WILL NOT SUPPORT ANY
SIGNIFICANT MILITARY ACTION
AGAINST RUSSIA UNLESS NUMBER
ONE, CONGRESS SPECIFICALLY VOTES
TO APPROVE IT AND NUMBER TWO, WE
HAVE THE NEW LEADERSHIP OF THE
DEFENSE DEPARTMENT AND THE JOINT
CHIEFS THAT WE NEED.
GETTING INTO SOME BIG DISPUTE
WITH RUSSIA OVER UKRAINE WOULD
BE INCREDIBLY MORONIC.
I'M SURE ALLIES WOULD SEE THE --
WOULD LOVE TO SEE THE U.S. TIED
DOWN IN EASTERN EUROPE.
WE HAVE TO RESIST ANY EFFORT TO
SURE UP -- STIR UP TENSIONS.
OUR MILITARY, ECONOMIC, NATIONAL
SECURITY FOCUS HAS TO BE ON THE
DANGER PRESENTED BY THE CCT.
WE JUST CAN'T AFFORD TO WASTE
TIME IN RESOURCES.
IF ANYTHING WOULD BE LOOKING FOR
WAYS TO PEEL RUSSIA AWAY FROM
THE CCP.
INSTEAD, RUSSIA AND CHINA SEEM
TO BE GETTING CLOSER UNDER
BIDEN.
HE'S BRINGING THE WORLD TOGETHER
AFTER ALL.
IT'S A NIGHTMARE SCENARIO FOR
THE U.S.
IN OCTOBER IT WAS JOINT NAVAL
DRILLS BETWEEN OUR BIGGEST
ADVERSARIES.
WE BIDEN PEOPLE ARE CLUELESS BUT
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE NOT.
THAT'S A SAME SURVEY NOTED 52%
OF AMERICANS SEE CHINA HAS THE
TOP THREAT, UP FROM JUST UNDER
40% IN FEBRUARY.
JUST 14% OF RESPONDENTS SAID
RUSSIA WAS OUR BIGGEST THREAT.
FINALLY, EVEN IF WE DID HAVE
GOOD REASONS FOR A CONFLICT WITH
RUSSIA, WHICH WE DO NOT, BIDEN
AND HIS TEAM ARE TOTALLY IN OVER
THEIR HEADS AND WOULD CERTAINLY
FAIL AT ANY MILITARY ACTION,
JUST AS THEY FAILED IN
AFGHANISTAN.
NATIONAL SECURITY ADVISOR JAKE
SULLIVAN, GENERAL MILLEY AND
GENERAL AUSTEN SHOULD HAVE ALL
BEEN BOOTED THE DAY AFTER HE
LOST 13 BRAVE TROOPS GUARDING
THE KABUL AIRPORT.
OF COURSE NO ONE WAS HELD
ACCOUNTABLE AND THEY SEEM TO
HAVE NO REGRETS EXCEPT THAT OF
COURSE LIVES WERE LOST.
THAT REFUSAL TO TAKE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR FAILED
STRATEGY ALONE IS A DISQUALIFIER
FROM FUTURE PUBLIC SERVICE.
LET'S NOT FORGET ANOTHER
TERRIFYING PROSPECT.
AMERICA AT WAR OR ON THE BRINK
OF WAR AND THEN SOMETHING
HAPPENS TO BIDEN, MAKING
KAMALA HARRIS OUR COMMANDER IN
CHIEF.
IMAGINE THAT FOR A MOMENT.
THE WOMAN CAN'T EVEN KEEP STAFF
LET ALONE KEEP TRACK OF MILITARY
MOVEMENTS IN EASTERN EUROPE.
HAVING SOMEONE AS UNQUALIFIED
AND UNTALENTED AND ON LIGHT IS
ITSELF AN ONGOING NATIONAL
SECURITY THREAT TO AMERICA.
THE BIDEN PEOPLE DIDN'T TAKE ANY
OF THESE JOBS SERIOUSLY.
IT WAS ONE BIG EXERCISE IN
DIVERSITY, EQUITY AND INCLUSION,
NOT MERIT.
AND NOW AMERICA IS PAYING THE
PRICE.
THE BOTTOM LINE IS: BIDEN'S GANG
WHO CANNOT SHOOT STRAIGHT MUST
NOT BE ALLOWED TO SQUANDER
AMERICAN LIVES OR RESOURCES ON A
DESPERATE AND UNNECESSARY
CONFLICT WITH RUSSIA.
ANY REPUBLICAN THAT IS STUPID
ENOUGH TO